[Musique]
bonsoir chers invités du thé d'aix
je suis fan iman ouedrago
affectueusement colonisée par les kangoo
depuis 2008
je suis originaire du village où
affectueusement on nous appelle kadhafi
muniz un dos parce que dans ce village
là qu'on nous pose une question on
répond toujours
tom mini z os et dans ce village on est
tellement direct que souvent ceux qui
sont pas de ce village se demande quand
on perd parle à son fils si c'est pas le
fils du voisin
bienvenue chez les accès bienvenue au
yatenga
passionné par les ressources humaines
j'ai travaillé pendant 11 ans dans ce
domaine sur différents postes chargés de
recrutement assistante
consultante puis drh
dire est prise dans un groupe
international
avec tout le confort qui va avec
j'avais pour feuille de route de mettre
en place le département rh de la filiale
burkinabè
j'avais cerise sur le gâteau j'avais la
confiance de mon directeur général et
surtout une vraie synergie avec mes
équipes tir
mais en novembre 2020
j'ai décidé de raccrocher
et de servir ma communauté
j'ai quitté cette belle opportunité pour
certains
mais j'avais juste à coeur de servir mon
pays et qu'est ce que je fais au service
de ma communauté aujourd'hui j'ai
développé un programme d'accompagnement
pour les veuves et les orphelins de
militaires tombés au front pour la
nation burkinabè
parce que je suis mariée à un ancien du
pmk qui est resté très attaché à ses
frères d'armes et quand nous sommes
entrés au burkina ma voisine de maison
son mari est commandant nos enfants joue
de temps en temps ensemble
et l'année dernière j'ai entendu parler
d'une attaque dans le nord et à chaque
attaque je vais la voir jusqu'où prendre
des nouvelles sans pour autant dire que
j'ai entendu parler de quoi que ce soit
on ne parle jamais du métier de son mari
l'armée c'est la confidentialité
mais ce jour là elle s'est confiée à moi
parce que je les trouvais meurtrie
elle m'a dit voisine je suis très
inquiète ça fait deux jours j'ai pas de
nouvelles et j'ai entendu que dans le
nord il ya des soucis
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire
j'ai regardé ses trois enfants je les
regardais et je les encourage et
et j'ai demandé la route
quand je suis arrivée chez moi j'ai dit
à mon mari
serge wawa heureusement que t'as pas
continuer dans l'armée parce que
j'aurais pas pu attendre comme ces
braves femmes j'ai de l'admiration pour
toutes les femmes de nos fds
parce que moi quand mon mari va en
mission
1h25 à abidjan je suis à ouaga mais je
voyage il n'a même pas le temps de
débarquer il me faut un petit sms je
suis bien arrimé arriver sinon ses
collègues ses collègues de bureau vont
entendre madame cambou téléphonie donc
imaginez si je devais le voir prendre
son sac à dos
partir sans être sûr qu'ils allaient
revenir
et ce soir là je me suis dit
on se dit que c'est dur on les encourage
mais concrètement qu'est ce que moi je
pouvais faire pour ces familles qu'est
ce que j'aurais voulu qu'on fasse pour
moi si mon mari était resté dans l'armée
ce soir là j'ai pas lancer de
responsabilité à qui que ce soit j pal
j'ai pas dis c'était la faute de x ou de
y mais quelle était ma partition en tant
que jeune burkinabè membres de la
société civile mon pays est en guerre et
ce soir là
j'ai commencé à écrire le programme
d'insertion pour ces familles et quand
j'ai finaliser l'écriture le 20 novembre
j'ai démissionné de mon poste et le 13
février 2021
j'ai lancé officiellement ce programme
c'est quoi le contenu de ce programme
ce programme c'est l'histoire de
juliette juliette elle a 21 ans elle a
une petite fille de 18 mois elle se
préparait comme nous allons nous
préparer bientôt à fêter le 24 décembre
juliette attendait son amoureux sa
petite fille attendait le père noël mais
ce soir là le père noël ne viendra pas
ce soir-là
son amoureux ne rentrera pas à la place
du père noël
une unité tapera à la porte des jupes et
en lui annoncera que son amoureux est
tombé au front à harbin da
21 ans
veuve avec une petite fille avec une
petite princesse de 18 mois
juliette dans son malheur
a quand même du soutien parce qu'elle
est entourée par sa famille et sa
belle-famille
beaucoup de juliette n'ont pas cette
chance d'étendre par leur belle famille
juliette va être prise en charge par
l'état via l'action sociale des armées
mais juliette aura du mal à vivre ce
veuvage elle passera ses journées au
cimetière
elles se posaient des questions qu'est
ce que je vais devenir
étudiante en gestion de projet licence
j'ai une petite fille de 18 j'ai pas
d'activité et j'ai pu mon amoureux le 13
février juliette va rencontrer un
programme un programme qui va lui offrir
une assurance maladie pour elle et pour
sa fille un programme qui va accompagner
sa fille dans sa scolarité
un programme qui va mettre un
spécialiste à la disposition de juliette
parce que le veuvage à levage c'est dur
à 20 ans
je n'imagine même pas
par la suite ce programme va et et
juliette a validé son stage de fin
d'études elle va rejoindre une
entreprise elle va finaliser son stage
aujourd'hui juliette et dans une
organisation
elle est assistante chef de projet
juliette est veuve 21 ans mais regarde
l'avenir elle se dit que demain sera
meilleur parce que s&p chez elle pourra
prendre soin de sa fille
ce programme nous accompagnons plusieurs
juliette avec différents profils des
juliet qui n'ont pas de diplôme et pour
c'est juliette là nous les aidons à
créer des activités génératrices de
revenus et nous les installons et nous
les suivre
nous avons des juliet étudiante élèves
et pour c'est juliette là nous les
aidons à poursuivre leur scolarité notre
dernière juliette a eu son bac avec 12
95 de moyenne
voilà l'essence même du programme que
j'ai mis en place avec mon équipe nous
apprenons à ces femmes à pêcher nous
leur donnons pas le poisson
beaucoup de personnes me demandent
pourquoi pourquoi tu quittes une
opportunité en cdi
une belle opportunité professionnelle où
tu pouvais faire carrière rester jusqu'à
la retraite
ce soir le télex me donne la chance et
l'opportunité de reprendre à tous ces
personnes
ma vie est une grâce
j'ai rencontré des difficultés
et pas l'aide
j'ai pu m'en sortir
quelles sont les grandes difficultés que
j'ai pu rencontrer
à 24 ans à la fac de droit de dijon je
préparais mes partiels
on m'annonce que mon père est malade
j'allais m'en occuper je me suis dit bon
ça un contrôle de routine deux mois
après
les médecins m'informe que il lui reste
en moins à vivre un mois il allait
arrêter les traitements
j'avais l'obligation et le devoir de
faire rêver mon père de prendre un
billet aller-retour pour moi ya pourtant
je savais que c'est un billet sans
retour
je me suis dit que
j'allais pas me relever de cette
difficulté n'ont au final
ça m'a fait grandir
j'ai pris 10 anni
j'ai essayé de m'accrocher à la vie
deux ans après
effectivement finalement il est rentré
un samedi le vendredi qui suit il était
parti nous avons fait notre deuil comme
on pouvait deux ans après avec mon
amoureux on décide de se mettre la corde
au cou un moment de joie je me suis dit
ah on à le remettre un peu de fun à la
maison
mais tout n'allait pas se passer comme
prévu
nous allons faire nos examens
prénuptiaux les médecins on me demandait
de rajouter une irm parce que cela
sentait pas bon du tout
et c'est irm l'avoir va montrer que
je fais partie des 190 millions de
femmes que fatima part évoqué tout à
l'heure
et cerise sur le gâteau
j'ai certes une endométriose mais pas
n'importe laquelle comme j'ai beaucoup
de chance via le dernier stade stade
4g l'endométriose partout sauf dans les
poumons et sur le coeur
avec les différentes avec les
conséquences je pas revenir là-dessus
passer facilement n'en parlez moi le
seul truc que j'ai retenu c'est que
impossible d'être mère pourtant mon rêve
quand on me posait des questions au
lycée c'était d'être maman accompagner
mes enfants et être une vraie belle mère
relou une nouvelle belle mère papa toki
ce qui prend tout en charge et ans
venait de m'annoncer que ça n'allait pas
être possible
mais j'avais quand même
fois
et j'ai demandé au médecin qu'est ce
qu'il fallait faire il m'a juste dit je
vous ça va être difficile ok mais il ya
quand même quelques solutions je vais
passer cette fois sur le billard on fera
trois fécondations in vitro
c'était pas vieux parce qu'il fallait
juste payer j'étais consultante à
l'époque donc payé j'avais un fixe et un
variable et le variable fallait juste
être kapitalis écraser les autres et à
la fin du mois je pouvais bien payé mais
fives
mon meilleur ami était
mon petit thermos avec les meilleurs
médicaments dedans guen et f décapeptyl
et les séries à 19 heures
que je sois en rendez vous en meeting ou
pas il fallait aller aux toilettes pour
se piquer j'étais très rigoureuse dans
mon traitement quatre ans de combat 0
locataires à la maison
les médecins ont décidé d'arrêter parce
que je suis passé de 40 kg à 80 kg on a
décidé de faire un break ce break là
j'ai fait une dépression ce break là je
vivais très mal cette situation
un beau matin j'allais à la gare c'était
un jour férié
j'ai vu une dame qui allait à la gare
aussi parce qu'il avait pas de bus
mocheté en voiture j'ai décidé d'être
gentil
je me suis dit bon j'ai quand même la
première et voilà et je les freeze dans
ma voiture
j'ai aidé cette dame est cette dame
a été une bénédiction pour moi parce
qu'elle m'a convaincu difficilement mais
j'ai rejoint une communauté une
communauté dans laquelle je vais
apprendre à aimer les enfants des autres
jeux va apprendre à manger avant de
m'occuper je vais faire l'école du
dimanche je vais aider mon prochain sans
rien attendre en retour je vais
apprendre à apprécier les femmes avec un
ventre rond
c'était pas facile et où ici dans ce
dense dans cette communauté je vais
aider des jeunes en difficulté à trouver
leur place à trouver une place dans une
entreprise à se reconstruire à avoir
grâce
auprès de leurs parents parce que
souvent en est ce qu l'enfant qui n'est
pas bons élèves souvent en famille
mais c'était difficile mais je vivais
autrement cette maladie
mais au final avec le soutien de cette
communauté le fait d'avoir appris dès
20h l'argent ne paye pas tout
je suis attendu n'en nommer trio stade
iv certes mais je suis maman de deux
locataires à la maison qu'ils ne payent
ni eau ni électricité
mais qui embête qui nous embêtent mon
adore ça et mon aile d'être une
belle-mère relou ça va être top j'ai
deux garçons donc les filles
après avoir vécu tout ça
pourquoi vous souhaitez que je te mettre
l'argent ou autre chose au devant des
choses de la vie
j'ai travaillé je pouvais payer les
traitements je pouvais me payer ce que
je voulais mais finalement ce que je
désirais le plus l'argent ne m'a pas n'a
pas réussi à me donner ça mais
l'entr'aide le fait d'avoir aidé une
personne
elle a été une bénédiction pour ma vie
et j'ai été une bénédiction pour la vie
de ces jeunes dans cette communauté
raison pour laquelle
de tous en retour au burkina faso
j'accompagne des jeunes burkinabè à se
réconcilier avec le marché du travail je
développe des programmes
d'accompagnement et aussi j'ai développé
ce programme go paga danton dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure
et pour finir
j'aimerais faire un appel notre pays
est en guerre notre pays rencontre des
difficultés et nous société civile nous
avons notre partition à jouer on n'a pas
besoin de donner à une organisation ou à
une association
mais chacun avec ses compétences
chacun dans son milieu de vie peut être
une bénédiction
pour les neuf nos fds vous pouvez
demander à vos enfants d'écrire un
courrier vous pouvez faire un champ que
vous allez donner à votre voisin fps
quand vous rencontrez un fds dans la rue
vous pouvez l'honorer c'est les fêtes de
fin d'année bientôt vous pouvez offrir
on n'a pas besoin de se mettre ensemble
pour aider si on n'a pas bu en a pas
envie on peut se mettre ensemble mon
père aussi le faire individuellement et
ce serait bien qu'on puisse participer
tous à l'effort de guerre quels que
soient nos propres convictions quelles
que soient nos croyances quelles que
soient nos différends
vision
essayons d'être des exemples essayons de
s'unir afin de tenir bon
afin de tenir bon le temps que cette
guerre quitte notre pays
et pour les grands frères qui sont en
entreprise ceux qui ont des opportunités
d'être manager d'avoir des postes à
responsabilité vous avez nos enfants en
charge en stage vous avez dans vos
équipes des jeunes qui travaillent qui
se battent soyez des bénédictions pour
ces personnes là ne les utilisez pas il
faut leur permettre de monter en
compétences parce que ce sont ces jeunes
là qui seront les managers de nos
enfants demain ce que j'aimerais qu'on
fasse pour mes enfants ou ceux que vous
aimerez qu'en face pour vos enfants
faites le parce que demain se prépare
aujourd'hui
merci de m'avoir écouté
que dieu bénisse le burkina faso
soldats le père dont le front bas le sol
en prière priant pour en retour son side
hier soldats ceux qui ont servi y est